on va rentrer par la grande porte
marylène et iza trias ont pris la clé
des champs dans ce mini bus complètement
modifié on a une table avec deux
banquettes pour s'asseoir puis notre lit
dans le fond avec des étagères pour
mettre notre linge un lavabo à pont à
pompe à eau qu'on aime glacial ont un
peu tristes heures on est classé avec la
glace qu'un petit pois l'once
une première escapade routière pour ces
deux étudiantes en travail social
on est parti de la tuque on a fait au
niveau du saguenay chicoutimi on est
allé voir un peu des randonnées
concernant dix ans
[Musique]
un itinéraire que bien des québécois
vont emprunter cet été qu'on parle aux
gens avec l'été qu'on l'a connue sous
celles qui ont fait le tour de la
gaspésie se sont donné rendez vous cette
année pour le tour de la côte nord qu'à
tout ça qu'est la première carte postale
qu'offre la côte-nord un village
essentiellement touristique
à preuve on y dénombre 800 habitants
mais les infrastructures municipales
peuvent accueillir jusqu'à 8000
personnes l'été on est surpris quand on
voit quelqu'un qu'on connaît
il y va on est surpris quand on voit
quelqu'un qu'on connaît pas le village
affiche déjà presque complet
si bien que la municipalité se préparait
des débordements ce terrain a été
défriché pour y aménager un nouveau
stationnement est capable sajoo fr peu
partout dont les gens prévoient les
municipalités prévoit des campings en
cas de débordement le surtout l'hiver un
point dépannage peut-être une huile on
veut pas créer un camping ni l'habitude
déjà de dire on part puis envers robin
et on ne veut pas non plus que les
touristes abîme les milieux naturels les
gens ils imaginent que parce qu'il ya
une grande nature que de fermer ou non
sur les dunes de tadoussac les messages
d'interdiction d'y passer la nuit ne
suffisent pas surveillé 24 heures sur 24
c'est très coûteux
ça peut être dans les cinq cent vingt
mille dollars il aide à certains
endroits faut presque le faire parce que
dès qu'on tourne le dos ça s'installe la
microbrasserie tadoussac se prépare
également à recevoir beaucoup de visites
passent pas la première fois qu'on se
prépare pour le meilleur n'est ce pas
avoir été aussi
aussi mouvementée que le dernier on a
fini par manquer bière on est vite mais
il n'ya pas que la bière qui risque de
manquer l'autre grande question c'est
est ce qu'on aura la capacité les
travailleurs et travailleuses pour
donner le service dans les restaurants
dans les différentes boutiques c'est la
grande question qui était de 7 doigts se
pose la microbrasserie double ses
effectifs pendant l'été mais le défi
cette année c'est de recruter des
employés malgré une saison plus courte
seulement maintenant qu'on a les seins
politique elle pour trois ou quatre mois
le matin ça va juste deux mots écrits à
la place
encore cette année la saison touristique
pas se limiter aux quelques semaines de
vacances de québécois un coup dur pour
l'industrie de l'observation des
baleines chez croisière à heml plusieurs
embarcations resteront dans les hangars
on a 60 et 5 pour faire des extras au
québec sans les touristes étrangers qui
arrivent généralement en me et qui
voyagent jusqu'à la fin octobre
l'entreprise navigue en eaux troubles et
trésorerie on y ont passé c'est c'est
quand même quelque chose d'incroyable dé
réduire son chiffre d'affaires de 75 %
la saison d'observation des baleines
comment sera au tour du 24 juin
trop tard pour que marylène ilaria
puissent en profiter
les deux étudiantes s'apprête à rentrer
à la maison la tête pleine de souvenirs
ici valérie gamache face au canada
tadoussac
[Musique]